[Music]
people are still mourning the death of
the Queen of Soul Aretha Franklin who
passed away last week in Detroit but
here is a shocking piece of news she had
no will so does that mean we're in for a
nasty family battle we begin tonight
with new information about who will get
her fortune and how much it could be
worth the Queen of Soul was intensely
private about her finances online
estimates put Aretha sportin at 80
million dollars but our sources tell us
the actual number is probably less than
that the singer had new problems her
fear of flying limited her touring and
she owned the publishing rights to only
a few of her hit songs Centurion gone
I wrote million selling record
[Music]
think I wrote million-selling record and
although a reason may have died without
leaving a will Michigan law is pretty
straightforward
Franklin's four surviving sons are
expected to split the estate that was
that motion in court papers filed
yesterday it's important to point out
though that there were two major
projects in the works that could involve
are--this family this is footage from
the recording of ERISA's 1972 album
Amazing Grace the unreleased documentary
was directed by the late Sydney [ __ ]
there were legal and technical issues
with the film through the years but
there's hope arenas heirs will now clear
the way for its release and as for a
movie on are--those life well one of the
producers told The Hollywood Reporter
yesterday it's definitely moving forward
the singer had originally wanted Halle
Berry to play her but Jennifer Hudson is
set to star that is my idea train roll
and that's something I'm extremely
passionate about and I'm ready I'm so
ready
[Music]